un grupo funcional es un grupo de átomos
y enlaces que poseen un comportamiento
químico predecible así que vamos a
tratar de cubrir digamos los más comunes
de los grupos funcionales que uno puede
ver en un en una clase de química
orgánica ya sea de preparatoria o de
universidad y puedes realmente agrupar a
estos grupos funcionales en tres grandes
categorías la primera categoría que
vamos a ver es en donde tenemos carbonos
con enlaces múltiples con enlaces
múltiples así que puedes puedes no sé
pensar en dos carbonos dos carbonos y
tienen un enlace doble entre ellos muy
bien entonces a estos de hecho ya los ya
los hemos ubicado déjenme cambiar de
color con los ejemplos ya los ubicamos
ya estos se les conoce como al que nos
verdad
al que nos y por supuesto cada uno de
estos carbonos debe tener cuatro enlaces
así que voy a ponerle dos de cada lado
de estos carbonos y estos están unidos a
algo que le vamos a llamar digamos
grupos r qué grupos r&r simplemente va a
representar como el resto de la molécula
ok puede ser cualquier cosa pueden ser
hidrógenos pueden ser cadenas de
carbonos o alguno no sea algún otro
grupo funcional muy bien no importa que
sea nos ayuda simplemente a enfocarnos
en lo que distingue a los a los grupos
al que no entonces son un ejemplo de
esto puede ser el siguiente
digamos tenemos nuestro enlace doble
aquí podemos ponernos un hidrógeno aquí
podemos poner un grupo metilo que lo
representamos de esta forma aquí podemos
poner otro hidrógeno y aquí un grupo de
tilo entonces como ven pueden hacer
cualquier cosa
estas ere verdad es decir por cada ere
distinto que yo puedo poner tendré
a un al que no diferente pero todos van
a hacer a comportarse de forma similar
van a reaccionar de forma similar vamos
a ver otro ejemplo esta vez en en lugar
de tener un enlace doble vamos a tener
un enlace triple entre estos dos
carbonos y por supuesto a cada uno de
ellos les falta un enlace en el cual
vamos a poner un grupo r y estos pueden
ser distintos verdad justo como en el
ejemplo anterior entonces a éste se le
conoce como 'la chinos
estos son los alpinos muy bien entonces
podríamos pensar en otro ejemplo
justamente que tengamos dos carbonos
unidos tenemos dos carbonos unidos con
un enlace triple ahí tienen un enlace
triple entre dos carbonos y a cada
carbono le unimos un grupo metilo
entonces este es un ejemplo de al kiel
al kilos
finalmente vamos a trabajar nuestro
último ejemplo de este tipo de grupos
funcionales en donde tenemos enlaces
múltiples y por ejemplo podemos poner
algo así digamos este es un anillo de
carbonos en donde hay enlaces múltiples
donde tenemos enlaces múltiples y de
hecho sólo pueden ser enlaces dobles
verdad sólo pueden ser enlaces dobles
no bueno quizás también podría haber en
las triples en fin vamos a tomarnos solo
esto y este se les conoce como anillos
aromáticos este es un anillo aromático o
también se le conoce con el nombre de
arena ok
quizás el nombre de haré no puede venir
de arte de aromático justamente y haré
no es bueno la terminación en o
justamente porque tiene enlaces dobles y
son al que nos verdad entonces un
ejemplo pues este mismo anillo puede ser
un ejemplo en sí mismo verdad podríamos
tener algo así este este anillo de 6
carbonos con tres de ellos teniendo
enlaces dobles
ahí tenemos este es un ejemplo de un
harén o y es un anillo de benceno este
es el nombre común de esta de esta
molécula y si por ejemplo aquí le
pusiéramos un grupo metilo entonces éste
se le conoce como metil benceno o que
también digamos su nombre más común es
el tolueno ok
así que esto agota todas las
posibilidades de mi primer categoría
vámonos con la segunda categoría la
segunda categoría agrupa a digamos todas
aquellas moléculas que tienen un carbono
unido unido con
con digamos con un átomo que es electro
negativo el electrón negativo ok
digamos esto es un poco ambiguo verdad
puede ser pero pero realmente la mayoría
de estos kind en caen muy bien en esta
descripción de que tenemos un carbono
con un enlace simple eso es importante
con un átomo el electrón negativo así
que si fijamos por ejemplo un grupo no
se r que tenemos digamos un grupo r
vamos a ponerlo aquí que está unido a un
átomo de nitrógeno entonces este otro a
este átomo de nitrógeno tiene tres
enlaces vamos a ponerle grupos r y
completamos con estos electrones así que
cuando tenemos este estilo de este grupo
r que tiene carbonos este si tiene como
terminación aquí un carbono lo mismo
en que está unido a nuestro nitrógeno
que por cierto es electro negativo
entonces esta configuración nos
determina una amina ok estas son las
aminas y podríamos dar un ejemplo
digamos aquí tenemos nuestro nitrógeno
ponemos un grupo de tilo otro grupo
estilo y podemos contar con un hidrógeno
muy bien podemos juntar con un hidrógeno
y esto es la dieta y la mina
entonces esta es la dieta y la mina qué
pasaría si en vez del nitrógeno
tuviéramos un oxígeno digamos que
tenemos un grupo r unido a un oxígeno
que se une a otro grupo r verdad
entonces tenemos completamos el octeto y
cuando tenemos estos pero en vez de esta
última r déjenme poner antes de esto
este este es un grupo funcional pero
antes de eso que tal que tuviéramos este
oxígeno unido a un hidrógeno entonces ya
lo hemos visto verdad este justamente es
un alcohol es el grupo de los alcoholes
ahora no no ya ya hemos visto este
ejemplo anteriormente tenemos por
ejemplo estos dos átomos de carbono
unidos a un h y a éste se le conoce como
el etanol ahora bien si nosotros
sustituimos esta h justa justamente como
teníamos antes por un grupo r tenemos r
con nuestro hidro perdón oxígeno
y otro grupo r entonces a esto se le
conocen como éter es el grupo de los de
tres
ok entonces por ejemplo podríamos tener
nuestro oxígeno con un grupo de tilo
otro grupo de tilo y aquí también
tenemos el dietil éter que por cierto
tiene como forma de pájaro no sé quizás
unos ojos y una boca verdad no sé fue
chistoso es vamos a ver qué tal que
ahora no tenemos un oxígeno que tal que
ahora tenemos un azufre el azufre se
encuentra digamos dentro de la tiene
características químicas similares al
oxígeno verdad que entonces podemos
tener esta configuración y qué tal que
este azufre como en el primer ejemplo
está unido a un hidrógeno entonces a
esta digamos a este tipo de moléculas se
les conoce como theo les ok un ejemplo
que podríamos dibujar es nuevamente
tenemos
átomos de carbono unidos a un azufre y
al hidrógeno y éste se le conoce como
etanol muy bien
qué otra cosa qué tal que en vez de
nuestra h ponemos justo un grupo r y
cambiando el oxígeno por el azufre
tendremos r ese que es el azufre y otro
grupo r así que cuando tenemos este tipo
de cosas tenemos un sulfuro muy bien
sulfuro y un ejemplo que podríamos dar
es algo similar como esta verdad tenemos
un azufre con dos grupos estilos y este
se llama dietil sulfuro muy bien el
último que vamos a ver dentro de esta
categoría es justamente cuando tenemos
un grupo r unido a un halógeno verdad y
que completamos de esta forma donde
halógeno pues son todos aquellos que se
encuentran en el grupo 17 como puede ser
el cloro el flúor o el bromo verdad
entonces a esto se le conocen como
haluros de alur o de al kilo
al duro de alquilo muy bien como se ve
esto esto se ve por ejemplo uno de los
uno de los ejemplos que son muy útiles
en el laboratorio es cuando tenemos esta
estructura unido a un cloro este sería
el termet el cloruro muy bien
vamos a movernos a nuestra tercera y
última categoría vamos a movernos y esta
categoría son todos aquellos digamos que
son nuestros grupos funcionales que
tienen un carbón doble unido a un bueno
unido con dos enlaces a un oxígeno
entonces esta categoría la categoría 3
sería cuando tenemos un carbono unido
con un enlace doble a un oxígeno ya
estos son los que les llamamos grupos
carbón y carbón y los que un grupo
carbón y lo es de esta forma aunque hay
entonces el primero de ellos sería
cuando tenemos un carbono con un doble
enlace a un oxígeno verdad y aquí están
sus electrones de acá y está unido a un
grupo r y aún aún hidrógeno a estos de
aquí se le conoce como aldehídos
aldehído aunque y su nombre viene de que
es alcohol deshidrogenada entonces un un
ejemplo que podríamos dibujar es el
siguiente tenemos nuestro carbono unido
con un oxígeno y con el hidrógeno y
luego tenemos estos estos tres carbonos
verdad podríamos a éste se le llama se
le conoce como bután al y por ejemplo si
la r este grupo de aquí que tenemos
fuera un hidrógeno a ese se le conoce
como formaldehído vamos a ver otros
otros
otros grupos funcionales que están en
esta categoría si tenemos ahora en vez
de esta h ponemos un grupo r verdad y en
este lado también está nuestro grupo r
nuestro oxígeno entonces a éste se le
conoce como cetonas este es el grupo de
las cetonas y otro ejemplo que podríamos
es justamente este pero cambiando el
hidrógeno por un grupo metilo si tenemos
algo así a este se le conoce como la
butano na ahora cuál es la diferencia
entre los aldehídos y las cetonas suele
haber mucha confusión pero no debe ser
tan complicado simplemente nos fijamos
donde está el grupo carbón y lo ubs aquí
me faltó dibujar el oxígeno entonces nos
fijamos el grupo carbón y lo si de algún
lado hay un hidrógeno inmediatamente
este es un aldehído si de ambos lados
hay un grupo r donde que tiene carbonos
entonces este es una acetona muy bien no
es tan complicado si si lo piensas de
esta forma sólo es cosa de ubicar dónde
está el grupo carbón hilo ahora bien qué
tal que tenemos nuestro carbono nuestro
grupo r el doble enlace con el oxígeno
ahora unimos con un nitrógeno que a su
vez está unido con dos grupos r ok y
este nitrógeno lo completamos estos de
aquí se conoce como amigas
esta es una amiga bueno vamos a ver un
ejemplo sería si ponemos esto así
tenemos aquí nuestro doble enlace con el
oxígeno unimos con el nitrógeno y este
nitrógeno se une en ambos lados con un
hidrógeno ok entonces este de aquí se le
conoce como bután a mida y la diferencia
con las aminas con n es que las aminas
no tienen este grupo carbón y lo verdad
en el grupo carbón
o más bien el grupo carbón y lo sólo
corresponde a las amigas si este grupo
carbón hilo no existiera entonces
simplemente sería una lámina como la que
vimos anteriormente ahora cual sigue que
tal que tenemos que tal que tenemos un
carbono unido con nuestro oxígeno de
esta forma nuestro grupo carbón y lo
nuestro grupo r ahora unimos con un
oxígeno
aquí estamos uniendo con un oxígeno que
a su vez se une con un hidrógeno aunque
entonces tenemos
la configuración ya este grupo funcional
es el de los ácidos carboxílicos ácido
carboxílicos
el ácido carboxílicos un ejemplo un
ejemplo muy sencillo sería por ejemplo
este que quizás ya lo has oído en varias
ocasiones tenemos esto unido al o h y
este es el ácido acético muy famoso por
por las cuestiones de limpieza y demás
sale entonces ese fue un ejemplo ahora
vamos a variar un poco qué tal que si
tenemos este oxígeno pero después nos
volvemos a unir con un grupo carbón y lo
es decir tengo esta ere este grupo r
nuestro carbono
el oxígeno unido a un oxígeno y éste a
su vez se une con un grupo carbon hilo
ok que le resta un enlace y puede ser
cualquier grupo r a estos los vamos a
conocer como anhídridos este es un
anhídrido un ejemplo muy muy rápido
puede ser éste
más así
de esta forma y simplemente unimos de
ambos lados con grupos metidos este es
el anhídrido acético y que sirve mucho
para hacer aspirinas verdad entonces
ahora vámonos con el último ejemplo de
nuestra de nuestra lista larga que hemos
desarrollado y es justamente el caso de
los halógenos qué tal que tenemos
nuestro grupo carbón y lo
y unido con un grupo r y unido con un
halógeno donde otra vez a lo que no es
cualquier elemento del grupo 17 de la
tabla periódica entonces a esto se le
conoce como al 1 de asilo al 1 de asilo
y otro ejemplo que podríamos hacer es
justamente para hacerlo rápido
si tenemos unido a un cloro muy bien
entonces
ahí tienen los grupos funcionales más
comunes y que verás en a lo largo de una
clase de química orgánica y yo pienso
que hicimos alrededor de 16 pero en
realidad hay muchos más que eso pero
estos son los que vamos a ver en las
reacciones de este curso